the third lecture of Aisha tremens thank
you coming back so normally in the
morning so let me go start by looking at
some of the concepts we saw yesterday
I'll be talking a lot about stable sets
and profit graphs today so yesterday we
defined the following concepts given a
graph alpha of G is the size of the
largest stable set so that's a set of
vertices in the graph such that there
are no edges in between them and you can
also look at the size of the largest
clique so that's the in the it's it's a
complete sub graph incomplete induced
sub graph and Omega of G is the size of
this largest clique and so one one the
first of us relation is that the size of
the largest clique is at most
the chromatic number Chi of G so Chi of
G is the minimum number of columns
needed to column all the vertices of the
graph properly which means that it's the
smallest number of stable sets that
cover all the vertices and this is
simply because if you look at if you
look at the largest clique then every
stable set so every column class in a
coloring can use at most one vertex of
the stable set
now when you so similarly you have that
if you look at the size of the largest
still on set you can complement
everything so this is the same thing as
Omega in the complement and so this is
also at most the chromatic number of the
complement the chromatic number of the
complements are just right it a sky bomb
of G so that's the smallest number of
clicks covering all jungchi's
now yesterday we introduced the notion
of a perfect graph and so you can so
let's look at two classes of graphs one
is that for any induced G prime we have
in this we have equality so alpha of G
prime I'm sorry Omega of G prime is
equal to Chi of G bomb and another class
of graph is for all induced
G prime we have that alpha of G prime is
equal to tribum of G so this is always
and so the so last yesterday I defined
these clients as the class of
photographs in fact implicitly I was
using the fact that these two classes
are actually the same and that's that's
a result of lo vas in fact what lova
showed was that this is equivalent this
is lova 72 he showed that this condition
is equivalent to saying that for all
induced subgraph
you have that Omega of G prime times
alpha of G prime is at least the number
of vertices of the graph and so that's
clearly symmetric when you take the the
complement and so that means that law
has also showed that this class of graph
is equivalent to that class of graph let
me so and yesterday we defined we
defined the step onset polytope as step
of G and we said it's just the convex
hull of all incidents vectors of stable
sets and then in particular I can so if
this is stab of GE
the following inequalities must be
satisfied by every stable set and that's
simply saying that the if I take any
clique clique and a stable set
intersecting at most one vertex and so
the sum of these X is at most one so now
if I take all cliques and consider all
these inequalities I get a belligerent Q
stab of G defining that way in terms of
its facets and that contains strategy
and so yesterday I introduced a an SDP
the theta the theta body that is that
for any graph is sandwiched between stab
and Q stab
and in addition I mentioned that from
perfect graphs you have equality between
throughout so stop of G is equal to Q
stop of G and also so that means that
you have equality then now I'd like to
correct something I said yesterday which
was incorrect so someone asked the
question about the strong profit graph
result and whether that led to an
algorithm for computing alpha or Omega
and so this is not the case so the
decomposition algorithm has been refined
but it has been refined to show that you
can recognize in polynomial time if a
graph is perfect or welcome it's not
known how to optimize these quantities
or from perfect graphs using just
decomposition to them however you can
optimize you can compute these
quantities in polynomial time using SDP
because as the P can be solved
efficiently up to an arbitrary precision
in polynomial time now let me first give
you some examples just in case you you
haven't been playing with graphs you you
live purely in the continuous form so
let me show you a few basic basic
classes of compa graphs and let me show
you a few things so first let's take the
case in which g is a bipartite graph
so what is the largest clique in G well
it's pretty obvious you can take at most
two of them sees in a clique because
it's bipartite so this is - what is the
number of columns you need you need only
two columns and so the chromatic number
of G is also equal to two and if you
take an induced sub graph of a bipartite
graph you still have equality so that
means that a bipartite graph satisfies
this it's perfect for that notion now
let's look at what this means so what is
if you have a bipartite graph what is
alpha of G well it's the size of the
largest a bomb set it's not true that it
may be one of the column classes it
might be might be that if you take this
vertex and I mean well so from choose
from both sides you might get a larger
more stable set but so that's the size
of the largest a bomb set and what does
what does the the clique covering number
means so what is gamma of G well that's
the smallest number of cliques that you
need to cover all the vertices so you
could try to take a matching and then
add some ID not everything is governed
in this case everything is covered but
so this is known as the edge covering
number
edge covering number of the bipartite
graphs oh so if if I was using Lovis
equivalence then this would show that
since this is Trivium that you have
equality
so that's trivial so this would imply
that the edge covering number of a
bipartite graph is you're always equal
to the it's stability number and this is
known as Koenig's eunuchs term for any
bipartite graph
the stability number is equal to the
edge covering number
so that's a typical it's a typical
min/max relation this is the minimum
number of edges required to cover all
the vertices
that's a maximization problem that's
maximizing the size of the largest table
set so that gives you a good way of
checking of checking if let's say a
stable set is maximum because I as a
certificate I can show you an edge cover
with size is equal to the size of the
stable set so so that's an NP intersect
onp characterization of these quantities
it doesn't give you an algorithm though
to compute alpha on to find the edge
covering number although this can be
done easily let me give you another
example if I take AG is a comparability
graph so in that case so that means that
the edges can be oriented into a
transitive a cyclic digraph so you want
to orient the edges in such a way that
it's transitive every time you have a
directed path you are going to sew the
edge the chantal page and so in a if you
take a comparability graph what is what
is for example the largest clique
the largest clique in the graph if you
think about it it's exactly the same as
the longest directed path in that
digraph so it's the number of entries in
the longest directed path in age and
what is what is the chromatic number the
chromatic number you have to use you
have to use for the chromatic number you
have to use stable sets so what is a
stable set in that case that's a set of
vertices that cannot be compared in that
digraph so so that's the
this is typically called a chain and so
the chromatic number would be the
minimum number of wrong cheese in what's
known as a 90 chain and so what
we have indeed that comparability graphs
satisfies this at equality because of
dalhwan's theorem so dalhwan's theorem
says that
that you have equality so that for any
any diagraph the largest chain is equal
to the the know what did I write minimum
minimum number of anti chains covering
minimum number of anti chains covering
so did Ron theorem is that Omega of G is
equal to Chi of G so I mean I could give
you lots of further examples of graphs
from which that aren't perfect from
which wave equality but what I'd like to
do instead is I'd like to instead of
continuing giving you examples I'd like
to to prove this these equivalents and
at the same time also proving this might
be a bit ambitious to do a full proof
under in the lecture but I'll try so so
let me and the proof is going to be
fully drawn so the the this is you might
say I mean let's say the equivalence of
this and that it may not look for Legion
but you really need a polyhedral
approach you really need in particular
you'll see there will be using duality
in improving this you really need that
in doing so so let me first look at the
weighted version of the largest clique
so let me define
suppose I have weights on the Von Teese
of the graph and now suppose I'd like to
look at the maximum weight click so one
way I could define it is the following I
could say I maximize the sum of W I X I
I'd like X I to be the incidence victim
of a click so I'd like this to be 0 1 5
VI and then I'd like it to be a click so
that will impose that from every stable
set I have at most one vertex in the
stable set so this is an integer program
defining the maximum weight click in a
graph and then I could relax these and
get a linear program so I get an upper
bound which is maximizing some of I WI X
I subject to X satisfying all these
constraints and also X I being a
negative so what I can select me from
write it down
but this is really the same as cue stab
except it's from the complement graph so
this is Q stab of the compliment
and now now I can use LP duality so what
does LP duality tells me tells me that
that max is equal to a min in the min I
have a variable for every step on set
and so I'd like to minimize the sum over
my stable sets s s of wires and then I
get that for every I have we I for every
I in V I have that if I look at all the
stable sets containing containing I this
should be at least WI and YS is
non-negative and and so what does that
mean if suppose that I could find an
integer solution to this so this is a
linear program this is fractional but
suppose I could find an integer solution
to this so then I would mean it would
mean that every stable set is as the an
integer multiplicity and then what I
what my stable sets do is that they come
from each vertex WI times so if the W is
1 1 it would mean that this would be the
chromatic number once I put the the
integrality so this since I'm fronting
restricting this is at most the when I
put integrality constraint I get the
chromatic number of G but with from a
weighted chromatic number of G so every
every vertex has to become WI times
so so imposing that imposing that for
example the the largest clique is equal
to largest clique is equal to this means
that throughout him
I have equality when W so if I'd like if
w takes values which are Edom zero on
one zero allows me to go to induced
subgraphs one if if all the WI is a one
I'm really defining W of G Omega of G so
that the clique number and the chromatic
number so so the film step of so there
are different ways of proving for
example the equality the equivalence
between this and that but one one key
idea is to use
is to use a replication lemma of low
VARs and
and so what it shows is the following
that if G so let me so again let me say
that this is what I will call G's
perfect
so application lemma of Lovis is the
following if that if G is perfect if I
take a vertex V and I look at its near
bonds and then i duplicate it meaning
that i put i put a new copy of V I put
an edge between them and I link that new
copy to all all the neighbors of V same
nail bombs so n of E the neighbors of V
is equal to the neighbors of V Prime
not quite because V the neighbors of V
container V Prime and the neighbors of V
prime contains V but kind of and so when
you do these replication what lova
showed is that this new graph G prime is
also perfect
it's not too difficult to show we could
show it but let's let's skip it for now
so so once you have this it's actually
not I mean it's pretty straight home to
get that that perfect means that him
you have equality throughout so this
would mean because you can you can
essentially replicate a vertex not just
once but you can replicate it let's say
WI minus one times and so because you
can always assume by scaling you can
always assume that I mean first you can
assume that this is a rational and then
you by scaling you can assume that this
is an integer so so that shows that if
you have this condition then in fact you
would have equality throughout so this
would be an equality and this would be
an equality now in particular this being
an equality means that this means that
since this is true for every W it means
that the convex hull of stable sets is
given by these inequalities so that skew
stub of G bonds so it means this implies
that the the convex hull of secure stab
of G bomb is equal to Q stab
giba ok so that's a good step but it
says more than that in fact so we so
this is a very important notion in
discrete optimization so not only we got
an integer solution in the primum but we
have also an integer solution in Doom
and so that's a so it's a stronger
notion so so it's related to the notion
of total dual integrality and in fact
having a solution an integral solution
in a dome for every W that integer
actually implies an integer solution in
the primer so if we had been able to
show just this equality for every W I
that integer then that would have
implied that equality as well that's a
it's an interesting notion of TDI nests
which are will not government but so so
now what I want to do is I want to
derive that from the integrality in this
room I'd like to derive that that I have
also the same property from Q stab of G
so what I'd like to show these places is
Perseus integrality of the doom I want
to show that this implies that stab of G
is equal to Q star Babji
so let's let's do this yeah yeah I swept
that under the rug so the thing is that
if if some WI is negative
you'd better not include it in the max
max max click because that would only
decrease the value so you can actually
eliminate these but you once you show it
from non negative ones you can then show
it show it also because you are
essentially taking an induced sub graph
so it's true for every W so the
replication lemma would be the following
so the replication lemma would say that
I would take my so I have a graph and I
have a W like for example I have let's
see this graph and W is 2 3 4 1 1 0
let's say 0 so what I'm going to do on
let's say 1 for now so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to duplicate these two
ones duplicate is twice these three
times and then I'm going to put a click
him a click him a click him and so on
and then join them do all the
connections and so I get a I get a note
on graph but from from this replication
lemma which which I haven't proved so I
would need a proof of it but it's not
that complicated then
from that I get that I get that this new
graph is perfect now in this new graph
you can show that the largest clique in
this new graph correspond to as the same
value as the largest weighted click in
the original graph that's one thing and
then you can also reinterpret these
coloring number in the original graph
and in the in in this duplicated graph
and so because the graph is perfect in
from this graph with unit weights you
know that this is equal to that and so
you have equality throughout ok so it's
very simple
nothing nothing fancy so so now let's
look at Q step of G so we take we'd like
to show that Q step of G is equal to
step of G so let me take a vertex of Q
step of G or actually maybe not
necessarily of context let me take any
point in Q sub of G and I'd like to show
that it's almost so instead of G so what
does it mean for context for a point to
be in Q step of G so so we haven't
proved that yet but so let's say let X
in Q stab of G so being in cube step of
G it means that for every clique I have
a weight of at most one so let me first
assume that X is rational so if X is
rational I can find an integer Q let's
say such that X Q is an integer vector
in our V so what it means is that if I
look at since I know that Y if we click
sum of X is at most one it means that
sum of Q X I Y we click
is that most queue so it means that if
these are the weights if these are my
weights
it means that the maximum weighted
clique in the graph is at most Q so that
means that Omega in G with respect to
these weights Q X is at most Q but I
just derived this so it means that I
just derived that Omega of G from vector
W is equal to Chi so this is equal to
Chi of G Q X and so this is at most Q so
what does that mean it means that the
weighted chromatic number of G from
these weights is at most Q so it means
that I have a bunch of stable sets I
have a bunch of stable sets I have at
most Q stable sets
let's call them as one up to ask you
let's say such that if I look at the
number of stable sets if I look at the
number of stable sets that come from I I
have at least WI of them which means
that at least Q X I covering I now I can
if if I verse if I have more than that
covering I I can remove some countries
from some of the stable set to have
equality so I could say with Q X i
stable sets covering I but if I have QX
i step on sets covering I when I divide
by Q I mean it means that I have a
convex combination of stable sets giving
me X because I just have that the sum of
the 1 over s I over I is actually equal
to this is equal to Q X so if I divide
by Q I get a convex combination because
I have Q stable sets have a convex
combination giving me X which means that
that X is in stab of G
I'm starting to regret to do a proof on
the bone but it's okay
so so what did we show we we from sure
that if we assume this then using this
replication lemma we can forget that
step of the complement of G is equal to
Q step of the complement of G but we
could also show a stronger result that
we are the integer dual solution and
from that integer dual solution we
actually derive that Q step of G was
equal to stop Oh G so so it means that
in that case we have the sandwich own
Tita body is indeed equal to step of G
and until the body is indeed equal to Q
stop of G now let me show let me at
least finish it I'd like to go him now
so I'd like to show that this is this is
true but so now that's that that's very
simple because what is what is alpha of
let me first say that I take the entire
graph what is alpha of G well alpha of G
is obtained by maximizing the vector of
all ones over the step onset polytope so
alpha of G is I take alpha of G I
maximize in the victim of all ones and I
get I get some stable sets that are
maximum now I know that step of G is
equal to Q step of G that's what I just
proved so if step of G is equal to Q
step of G it means that ifv's I can use
LP duality because I have a complete
description of step of G so I have a
complete description of Q step of G in
terms of linear inequalities so it means
that by optimizing or from stop of G I
get a corresponding dual solution now
dual solution will put weights on
cliques so we'll put weights on cliques
so now let me take just one click in
that dual solution that has a positive
weight so by complimentary slackness
that will say that that clique intersect
every maximum stable set so what I have
now is I have a
so the fact that stub of G
the fact that step of G is equal to Q
stop of G means that if I look at alpha
of G and I could have done it for any
induced subgraph but I'm just doing it
from the graph I have that there exist a
clique such that the clique is a
non-empty intersection from every
maximum stable set s
but that's good because I take my click
this is my click and I delete that click
so I take the graph - the click
how will how with a stable stability
number of that graph B well it's going
to be at merge the stability number of G
but it cannot be equal to that because
every maximum stable set intersect my
clique so if I delete my click I lose
one I lose I must lose one because if I
delete the click ever since every stable
set intersect my click every maximum
stable set intersect my click I lose at
least one it's it's less than equal to
but it's also equal because a stable set
can have at most one vertex in common
with a clique so so you have equality
him but by you can you can continue you
can go to this induced subgraph and
indict induce sub graph instead of
having all all victims one you you put
some of the Wis to be 0 so you you can
continue and get another clique and
again decrease the stability number by
one and so what you get is that I will
get a number of cliques I will get a
number of cliques equal to the stability
number of the original graph so that
shows alpha of G is equal to Chi bomb of
G but I mean implicitly and I kind of
mentioned it you can go to the induced
sub graph by just setting some of the
weights to 0
okay so so now we prove that this
implies that and vice versa by doing
this Polly John proofed in which we did
show as a by-product that the stability
number of G is equal to the Q strategy
so
so one thing I'd like to emphasize is
that it was quite important not just to
get integrality but also an integral
doing solution and this was a key in in
getting in getting the argument wok and
you cannot always do that if I have time
I'll show you a some of some other
examples in which of these integrality
in the do one is not is not true so one
one question that I find interesting is
that the so you can decide if a perfect
graph is is if a graph is perfect in
polynomial time using these using
refinements of the decomposition theorem
that came from the strong profit graph
conjecture but it would be very nice to
be able to to decide in polynomial time
if a graph is perfect
based on these theta body so you know
that you know that step of G is equal to
the theta body if and only if the graph
is perfect and so would be nice to have
a polynomial time recognition are going
from perfect graphs based on these fact
so you could try of course to optimize
in a direction and then if you get a
point
that's not in if you get a point of T of
th that's not in stab then you know that
it's not perfect the problem is that of
course it could be like this and you
don't know how many directions you would
have to take so that's pretty obvious
yes certification right okay now I'm
trying to convince you that lying on my
graph is perfect isn't like an easier
or is it anyway that doesn't rely on the
structure of you know
so no this is not fully understood yet
yeah is there any hope like I mean if
you found the vertex that like was an
integral or something like this that you
could transform it into like an all pole
or I mean the the problem is that of
course I mean I can take I can take a
graph that's perfect
and I can add a little all young just in
a little column it's not going to be
perfect the problem is that you can look
in many directions it may not involve
this odd hole so so you can just if you
so to prove the perfect this drunk
perfect graph theorem you need to prove
that these are holes and holes
characterize them and I was sort of
wondering if you could have any hope of
Reax tracting a different proof but from
the fact that you you have some non
integral vertex and like trying to use
that to find but I mean when you I mean
yeah yeah possibly I don't know so I
mean let me mentioned a quick a quick
related characterization of a phone for
graphs which is
nonlinear in just a strong continuous
another continuous film to it and that's
through the notion of graph entropy so
suppose
so suppose I have a graph G and I I take
a probability distribution on on V and
now let me define the graph entropy so h
GP with respect to this probability
distribution to be equal to the
following convex optimization problem
so it's minimizing minus the sum over i
envy of p i times log of x i so that's a
this is a convex function of X subject
to X belongs to the stable set polytope
of G
so let's quickly see one key suppose I
take the complete graph KN so when I
take the complete graph to K and what
are the stable sets of the complete
graph these are just a single context
and so in that case the stability the
stable set polytope is just the simplex
and so when you when you do this when
you minimize this over the simplex you
get that this is equal to minus the sum
over I envy of P I log P I that's going
to be the optimum pi5 every vertex and
so this is just the Shannon entropy
so one one thing that one can show is
that for any two graphs F and G the
entropy of the Union and by Union I mean
just take the union of the edges so
these are two graphs on the same vertex
set let's see so so both on V V
something and so the same context set
and so the entropy on the Union and can
show that this is actually funny two
graphs V is at most the entropy you have
less than the sum
and so now you might so let's see what
happens when I put when I put a graph
and it's complement so for graph and its
complement
so for graph and it's complement I get
that H of K n of P is at most H of G of
P plus h of the complement of P and so
as I said this we know what it is it's
the Shannon entropy of P and so you can
ask when do I have equality and so
it's the five and gearing turn so let me
try to I need some help from in gains in
the audience and let's say at all so
they show that G G is perfect if and
only if you get that H of P is equal to
H of G P Plus this on every P so again
you can compute you can compute this
easily this is just we we could I mean
from if the graph is I mean if the graph
is perfect you can replace the him T H
of G and so you get a semi definite
program with a convex objective function
problem is that for some P again you
might be unlucky and and you might have
equality even though the graph is not
perfect so that's another another only
the result that would indicate that
maybe semi-definite programming could be
used to decide if a graph is is perfect
and
this entropy does it help like yeah so
it does it does but I yeah I don't want
to get into that we can do that are
flying maybe so let me mention for
example that let me say just one thing
that is graph entropy for example has
been I mean in terms of discrete
application it has also been used for
example from the by Canon Kim to to do
sorting of columns in which so if you
start from a partial order one you have
to decide which comparison to do next so
that to get a total on if you'd like to
minimize the number of of of operations
of comparisons that you'd like to mean
to do you can use graph entropy to do
this now the so how much time do I have
I've six minutes also
let me
let me move to a different topic in
briefly so what we did was we
we obtained some min/max relations and
one thing that was important in in the
proof as I said was the the integrality
in the doom
let me mention some other min max I mean
down countless of min max relations but
let me mention one that I very much
liked in that has some nice again nice
nice application that that's that no one
knows how to derive otherwise so let me
like to be difficult to do in five
minutes
let me say it this way so suppose so one
problem that has been very much looked
at recently is the in in terms of how
well we can approximate it is the
Traveling Salesman problem and the
Traveling Salesman problem were given a
metric space and we'd like to find the
tomb of minimum total length and you can
try to relax it and so one one way you
could try to relax it you could in
polynomial time you can compute the
so-called Eldon camp bound from 1971
which what you would do for example is
to minimize over all edges of the
complete graph and online this C exe
sees the the length subject that for
every if I look at every cut I need to
have at least two edges in my tomb that
and so I'm going to write that as some
of them II in Delta s is that affects C
is at least two for every s actually
non-negative typically there are some
additional degree constrains that one
can show you can remove them so let's
let's not bother with them and so
clearly the if I look at the value of
the TSP or the value of of these LP
Emily this is at least that now suppose
you can still get something in between
so you could look at what happens is if
I insist that X is integral if I insist
that X is integral I get that this means
that in every card I have at least two
edges which means that I'm looking at
the two edge connected subgraph problem
and I will get a value that in between
in between chk and C TSP so a major a
major question is whether whether the
supremum over all c of the ratio between
this and that
is equal to phone sound it's known that
it's at least phone sound and it has
been proved 40 years ago on 75 years ago
that it's at most three halves but it's
not known whether it's phone summoned
but you could ask an easier question and
what's the ratio between these two in
the wrong skis so you could look at you
could look at what's the
what's the Supreme ovum or C of the cost
of the TSP divided by the cost of the
two edge connected and in that case one
can show it's from sound and this is a
10 because you could have a metric in
which you have let's say two points that
are far away and three paths and so
essentially the best salesman would have
to go once twice three times and go back
to the origin spending let's say from D
so if if it is D then this would be 40
but the best to two edge connected
subgraph is just to take the three paths
so so that ratio the claim is that it's
at most two thrown and so this is a
result of of manma Benson and pulley
Blanc
and there is a very easy proof if you
use if you use these duality from
discrete optimization so what's the what
do you need to do you take the optimum
two edge connected subgraph whatever it
is and then you'd like to transform it
into a tomb so what you do is you look
at the vertices that have odd degrees
because these are the bad memories you
look at the vertices that are degrees
you let them be T and then what I'm
going to do is I'm going to add a sub
graph I mean let's say I'm adding a
matching on Jesus so if I add a matching
then all the degrees become even and so
and so then I can do the shortcut and
get an under / bound on this so that
would show that this is at most so I
mean we know it's at least for something
but so this would show that it's at most
also so now how do you and how what you
need to show that it's at most from
someone you need to show that the cost
of the matching on these on these on C's
is at most one found of the cost of the
two edge connected subgraph and so so
this is not that easy to do
but you can do there is a very nice
polygon proof that shows the following
you say that let me do the following let
me take my graph let me put one found on
every edge of the two edge connected
graph and and then I will look at the T
joint polytope
and what is what is the teacher what is
a teacher in what is a teacher in
polytope the T joint is simply
generation of matchings it's a sub graph
which has odd degree advances in T and
even degree advance is not in T so for
example you could take this path and
let's say that path that would be a T
John and so you could look at the convex
hull of all t joins and one can show
that if I look at the T joint polytope
and I look at everything above it so if
I add V E Plus so if I look at
everything above it it's actually equal
to the set of X such that for every cut
s intersect T is odd for every cut in
which this is odd that this should be at
least one and now we're not done because
if I look by putting a thumbs the thing
is that I cannot get an odd cut that has
at most two edges in it because if I
take an odd cut so if I take an odd cut
since my graph is two edge connected the
number of edges in the cut has to be odd
but it's an odd number but it's at least
two because it's too much connected so
it has to have at least three edges and
so it means that since I'm putting a
thorn on it some satisfy all these
inequalities and so it means that a
thumb is a convex combination of T
joints and since it's a convex
combination of T joints it means that
one of them is at most at some times is
because my convex combination has this
cost
now I'm mentioning this because if you
want to prove that this is this is the
polytope you could try to look at the
dual and so on but in this case you
could not get an integer solution to the
dual the doing would be only half
integrals so if if the cost are
integrins integers then in the dual you
you would get a half integer solution so
it's a I mean it's not very difficult to
prove it when can show this and so
that's so let me open time so so today I
decided to do something much more
communitarian because you probably were
a bit sick of despite the beautiful
actions of Pablo of all these semi
definite programming and you'll have a
lot of sum of squares in the elections
to come so I decided to do something
purely combinatorial and
based on on min/max relation in duality
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
good because the last lecture so for
people who are in the program I want to
kind of get get more immersed in this
kind of this kind of reasoning so may
have been continuous I commute you up
any pointers for weird good starting
place because I took your course forgot
I forgot to be this 2500 but it's so the
three-volume book by Lex craving is it's
the Bible so when you expand the proof
it's it's a bit more
[Applause]